what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we're here to watch the
second episode of The Last of Us once
again joined by my buddy man who have
talked about this game with constantly
over the years Andrew Gordon Igor
7-Eleven how you feeling Andrew I'm
feeling good and Craig's line that's all
we ever talk about it's just the last of
us when he calls me says Hey Last of Us
ladies and gentlemen you know it's due
leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated also subscribe and click
that notification Bell to get notified
when I reaction for the next episode of
The Last of Us is up here on the channel
as always full anthraction watch along
as we sync it with your own copy of The
Last of Us available for our super sexy
Rejects at our patreon page we'll
recover several shows exclusively with
reaction highlights and watch alongs
included Thanksgiving another disclaimer
here if this is your first time watching
with us yes we play the game but we will
not spoil anything that could possibly
happen in the future of the show since
this show seems to be pretty faithful to
the actual Source material we'll only
talk about specifically this episode
anything about how correlated the game
itself and another mention John and Tara
Erickson who haven't played the game
will be continuing their reactions right
here on this very Channel this week
alrighty guys let's get to it
20 30. Indonesia
two days before outbreak day interesting
is she a scientist or something
Professor mycology okay yeah all right
feels like Matthew Broderick and
Godzilla when he's studying worms
foreign
[Music]
oh
get out now
that was a really good addition I love
that yeah
Gore
[Music]
um
you got 48 hours
foreign
back to what really matters that's a
really great openness especially with
you know like how sci-fi the world is
and makes it feel that much more real
when you do stuff like that in the video
games we'd only been told about how they
studied it and learned about it and now
actually seeing it and also in a
different country too worldwide spread
yeah exactly we're also seeing a
scientist like understand the
ramifications like we're we're screwed
oh wow
foreign
like just waiting for her to turn do I
look like I'm infected choose your arm
I like this interesting add-on yeah it's
not getting any worse is it
what was Marlene doing with an infected
kid I'm not infected
test you how I have to pee test you
you know I think what really impressed
him was the fact that I didn't turn into
a [__] monster
back there you can find a spot
in here oh yeah I have to learn to trust
tear out a few pages
there's not gonna be anything
just you
are funny
I feel like something bad in there is a
reference to uh something that happens
later on in the game you need to stop
talking about this kid like she's got
some kind of life in front of her
is that chicken
yeah probably until they get it from
Smugglers
that's not you guys
we're doing this for us because because
apparently you're worth something but we
don't know what you're worth if we don't
know what we have
so answer my question you told me not to
tell anybody that I'm telling the first
people that
we've heard this a million times
vaccines miracle cures none of it works
thank you man I didn't ask for this you
and me both this isn't going to end well
test I was so Ellie if they believed
that she is
we get what we want oh you'd be hoping
she so much as twitches
I'm loving the Rapport between the three
of them fella Rhymes is great can I have
a gun absolutely not okay
throw a sandwich at them
yes
oh yeah
even the door opening sounds like a
clicker it's foreshadowing yeah
goodness the attention to detail it's
it's unbelievable
yeah that looks so real yeah
[Music]
km HBO you don't throw down we should
get moving
oh
I'm a dick is this where they bombed
yeah
they hit most of the big cities like
this
look at that God damn the detail I know
the attention to detail it's really
unbelievable pure Recreation long way or
short way it's the long way or the whiff
and dead way well I thought long way is
based on that limited information
foreign
so it was just you in there alone
yeah
ah how old are you
14. same age
is in the game mommy you got some balls
on you sister
thanks
I like fleshing out the relationship
more there's a lot more character
moments in this for sure watching it
grow nobody's gonna be coming after you
right like Mom boyfriend I'm an orphan
and uh no no boyfriend
did that reference so there aren't super
infected that explode fungus spores on
you or ones with split open heads that
see in the dark like bats will we see
that this episode
[Music]
what was that
say it let's keep moving just identify
it I just want to hear you say the words
oh my God looks just like the hotel I
know it's amazing oh my God that's
really cool they got Neil druckman to
direct this you want to stay in a place
like this
uh no a little out of our league I don't
even know what this is have you heard of
books
wait are we going in there yeah we gotta
get to the stairwell on the other side
can't swim I I don't know how to swim
how'd you know that
so gross
I love the sense of awe and the feeling
of Adventure that Bella Ramsay's able to
emote
[Music]
kind of sweet please yes ma'am right
away man I'm a weird kid
[Music]
foreign
look at his reaction to that
hey are you sure I have touched her you
know if there's also the feeling of the
intimacy of that
the anticipation
what the [__] did that happen gotta
search the place one of the fun Parts
well I mean maybe I could climb up there
yeah yep yes
never thought I'd be so excited about a
boost
I'm gonna need a few minutes
awkward
where'd you learn to do that the circus
where are you from
a forced conversation what about tests
Detroit it's in Michigan I go to school
I know where Detroit is
how long do infected live Oh I thought
you went to school it's a really shitty
one
well some last about a month or two but
there's others been walking around but
20 years
what now
oh there's a swarm of them
put them in danger
[Music]
do you respect the choice to shoot a lot
of this handheld gives it a little bit
more of an disorienting real feeling
wow
oh my God that's a lot of bodies
that is
insane that's a disturbing image
oh the sky the fungus also grows
underground you step on a patch of
cordyceps in one place and you can wake
a dozen infected wow interesting you're
not immune from being ripped apart it's
important I'm trying to keep you alive I
like how she's becoming a bit of a
mother but she knows how important she
is Museum
whoa
[Music]
It's like Neil druckman's wet dream come
alive
it's bone dry could mean they're all
finally dead in there
it's a really interesting new detail we
learned
congratulations
[Laughter]
such a shot I love how weary and beaten
Pedro Pascal's interpretation is he's
just like depressed
or in the museum guys we're in the
museum this is awesome oh the tension
oh just a hat remaining there
yeah
oh
[Music]
did he leave a letter yeah that's pretty
fresh body
[Music]
here
okay from this point forward
[Music]
not quiet oh it's good
yikes
wow
be quiet
man this production design is phenomenal
it's amazing
oh my goodness
[Music]
you're making so much noise just a
little bit
God
oh that noise effects
[Music]
goodness
oh my goodness
[Music]
attention never been so excited for
people in such a scary situation
damn they got the body language down
perfectly yeah
oh she's gonna freak out
[Music]
[Applause]
damn that's scary
shoot the head
he's surviving longer than you would in
the game
that is terrifying
[Music]
hey Captain oh is this smart smart or a
little tougher to defeated in real life
than in the game
[Music]
oh I love the specifics here
no
oh no
I'm loving it
oh my God it's like Ellie show man yeah
use your knife Ellie
[Music]
no
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
yes they are much more tougher to kill
than this you're right
you all right I love how they captured
so much of that just from our
character's perspective I didn't [__] my
pants
we're with you Ellie
you think change again she should get
bit every episode
see
nothing's happening
oh I think you guys are going to need a
plank
they have a plank already in place
oh my goodness did you just take the
good news I did it for once maybe we can
actually win we'll just go and go and
watch her hope
[Music]
it's interesting seeing someone put Joel
on his place though
oh a test
is it everything you hoped for jury's
still out
[Music]
uh yeah
come on the Ellie Angel
they're doing it man
they've really succeeded haven't they
this is this is great this is great
looked at the watch that was a nice
little moment right there just some nice
little subtle detail reminded of Sarah
getting close to the Capitol Building or
the State Building as they call them
this one
oh
oh I just saw something
oh yes
[Music]
uh man imagine going through all that I
mean it's got to be a
radio or something right in the game she
said a map or something
the healthy ones fought the sick ones
everyone lost one of them's got to have
a map on them yeah Tess
it's over we are going home
it's coming our luck had to run out
sooner or later
one more episode yeah
it sounded just like Ellie show me
wow this is like word for word
yeah oh no take your bandage off
it's smart to have her get bit again I
need you to get her to Bill and Frank's
he'll take her off your hands they'll
handle it from here no no no I can't
they won't take her they're not gonna
take her cause you'll convince them
man
please
[Music]
oh
oh no
what an interesting that was a really
interesting addition
oh my God
it makes sense now they just don't react
to sounds it's like a signal definitely
a big change from the game too
yes Tess
wow
[Laughter]
you
[Music]
have to
oh
man this one is harder
oh later turned on please
oh come on
[Applause]
[Music]
oh are we getting stalkers looks like it
oh
[Music]
God
yes
[Music]
oh wow
that is amazing
go Tess
meet your new daughter
as it's the connected mouth-to-mouth
made sense that is disturbing yeah
I thought they were gonna cut right
before we got they're so glad that they
wow
jeez that was nuts yeah my the pacing of
this show never feels like the actual
length that it is yeah yeah that was
gripping
oh man that was uh
you know like because it was crazy
because that's as seen in the end is
like when when she reveals that she's
been bit in the game you mean in the
game is like it's like word for word
but it actually hit me much harder here
because of the amount of time we've
spent with Tess and developing her and
the scenes all the scenes combined
uh and and
because because it seems that I remember
the first time playing the game and
being like oh this is really sad
that kind of I kind of saw this coming
like the first time I played like I
predicted that this would probably
happen
um saw two to my own horn it just felt
like that's probably what's gonna happen
yeah and here though I found myself
going please don't kill her off this
episode I know she has to die yeah but
well can we just like you know maybe
stretch that thing out to like a later
episode can we hear like what my third
episode because she's so good yeah and I
was so invested in her and uh I was
actually gonna I never like got like
super emotional uh when in the game but
in here that that definitely I was
getting a little misty out when it
happened yeah you make a good point I
mean we get a lot more character moments
especially between the three of them
whereas in the game again we still got
some character moments in the game for
sure it was still really good but here
it's it's stretched out a lot more we
get like just I mean we get that awkward
conversation between Joel and and Ellie
and then again the conversation just
where they're having the sandwiches it's
just again just really good rapport and
really good character moments I really
love the addition at the beginning of
the episode where we're seeing like the
worldwide effect of right before
outbreak Dave where the scientist uh is
studying it and like oh my like bomb the
city like I just I thought that was such
an interesting touch because again in
the video game it was just touched upon
that again it's the quarter steps
disease they studied it and you know we
don't really know like we didn't really
get to see this uh the scientists
studying it so to see the effect like
before it happens it just it adds a
different layer now that you can put in
your head when you play play the game
like oh now I know what what happened a
couple days before I know what the
scientists went through and like the
explanation of it and I just I really
again this is I apologize this is
probably the last time I'm going to
mention this I really hope did someone
at Disney is watching this show and just
having an understanding this is how live
action remakes that they do I this is
how it should be done again we're only
two episodes in you know we still got
seven more episodes but I'm just I'm
really you're gonna hear this from me a
lot I'm loving the additions that they
make some of the changes that they make
yes there are some things that they're a
word for word line for line there are
some things that they're doing but
they're doing it you know sporadically
they're not doing it it doesn't feel it
doesn't oh sorry to cut you off I was
just on that point like it doesn't feel
perfunctory it doesn't feel like we have
to do this it like seamlessly weaves in
to a word for word moment yes like like
when they're looking at the the tower
after the clicker scene or thank you um
yeah on the plank like that whole scene
was like wow that's right from the game
or or the scene when Tess reveals that
she's been bitten like that's right from
the game I mean they've obviously
changed some stuff at the end but they
it I love that it never just it never
feels like there's doing from the game
because they have to do it from the game
it they the way they they transition
into him like oh man I would have I
would it never feels out of place like
if I've never played the game I would
never question the scene or something
like that where I'm like are they the
scene feels odd are they only doing it
because it's something with the game it
is so natural it feels completely
natural but they've added some [__] in
here like with the rules of we learned
uh from heavy spoilers breakdown that
they're gonna there's not gonna be
spores which is a bummer to me but
they've added there's a whole other
thing with like a hive mind yeah where
you know what's that a signal like that
is really that's interesting actually
because again in the games we'd uh we'd
learn like oh no they react obviously we
know clickers you know they they only
they react to echolocation they can only
hear you know sound like a bat but we
figured in the game that they only come
when they hear noises they're going to
come towards you and that perspective
but now like this whole thing where you
know the spores come Underground when
they feel like one of them has died and
now sends out a signal to the other
one's laying on the ground like that's
really provocative that's interesting
like that's a cool new layer to it it
makes the it adds a new layer of it's
like it's a great way to supplement the
whole thing of sports with something
else yeah for sure that enhances the the
the idea of of sneaking around because
you know like in the games and [__] like
you have stuff where your plane is old
you can like hear really far away and
everything listen mode yeah yeah yeah
you could enhance that whatever
um so to add to add different obstacles
and different Stakes to the equation of
something like that is is gnarly and
yeah I mean of course you got to address
the thing uh for for gamers that the way
they because yeah at the end like Tess
is like you guys go and uh but it's oh
God who who shows it's civil guys show
up it's fedra I think it's Federal it's
definitely guys I don't know it's either
hunters or it's fed red so it's one of
them something like that but it's
obviously it's not infected in the video
game like this but this wasn't I like
the change made here well it made
something that felt more it felt Bleaker
felt a little bit more poetic uh for her
to go out like that and we got to see it
too rather than like it was just in the
background where you know if you get in
the video game she got shot and then we
saw from Joel and Ellie's perspective oh
no she's been shot and like what like
now you gotta run but like actually
seeing it it just it was more
gut-wrenching exactly it was way more
heartbreaking and uh it's so much more
Bleak the way she dies this way too as
well just exactly what with the lighter
that's a great call yeah yeah I mean uh
erupting It Up in Flames with the things
she's about to become you know like she
she takes them all out before she
becomes this thing that is literally
connecting to her pretty much welcoming
her in to the new family you're part of
this courtesy fungi family now and she
just won't she rejects it it's it's
insane and I love the direction by Neil
druckman on this because the way he toys
with perspective especially like with
the is that for sure a stalker looks
like a stalker it was a stock yeah for
sure but the way the stalker
um comes into frame like how it's it's
over her shoulder but it's blurred for a
while before it comes in a frame or like
the scene with the clickers
he usually he locks on the the and then
the first episode does this a lot too
they lock on to perspective of a
character we're watching in the scene
and how they're experiencing and
witnessing similar to like when you're
playing a game and you're getting a POV
experience you you see it through the
characters povs on things without just
like cutting directly to them a lot of
the time like sometimes you do but more
often than not you're just with the
characters yeah well I think it adds a
lot of tension too I just I keep feeling
like 80s or 70s John Carpenters
directing these scenes uh the the horror
scenes I mean it's just amazing and we
got to talk also about the stalkers and
the clickers the attention to detail if
we talked about the the visual details
in terms of the museum the planks and
all that other stuff the the sound
design the clickers the stalkers it's
it's it's just so beautiful it's real
it's it's it's it's daunting It's
haunting it's scary but it's so
beautiful at this same page it is
beautiful because you're like it's it's
it's mesmerized I I mean it is cured
like we have John and Tara doing
reactions uh for who haven't played the
game but from like a from people who are
in love with the game it is beautiful
it's mesmerizing when you're like wow
they've really brought the thing I love
to life you know it's it's in it's
gnarly and I can only imagine for Neil
druckman to be experiencing this like
didn't I direct this before oh no no
this is better well I think did he
direct them I know he directed the
second game did he direct the first I
believe he directed for sure the
director of that one there was you made
a point while we were watching that I
like was thinking in the moment but you
said it first the body land body
movements and body language of the
people and the click the the stunt
people doing the the clicker Motions
like it was spot on just spot on they
should make a an immersive experience I
think they should do something they
should build something where you I would
gladly pay like fifty dollars to go like
I'll do a walkthrough let's go let's do
this thing it'd be awesome to see if
brought to life because clearly they can
do it because yeah I mean when I was
looking at this the the buildings and
stuff you're like okay yeah that has to
be green screens there's no way they
build that [__] so it has to be green
screen the green screen is is impeccable
there's only a few times I could tell
with some of the king like okay yeah
that's definitely a green screen but
more often than not it's seamlessly yeah
you cannot tell it it Blends so well the
production design is phenomenal
especially too when you see like
the spores and the wall I mean not the
spores but like the the remains in the
wall of people who uh become infected
it's like yeah it's so it's so
phenomenal it's the production design
like absolutely fantastic in this show
and I just again this episode was great
I I really love you also mentioned too
during the beginning of the episode like
it's interesting to see the beginning of
the episode start from the past how they
were doing a little bit of non-linear
storytelling so I'm hoping like that's
something that they keep continuing on I
hope that I mean we're talking also too
about possibly seeing like uh where we
did another video maybe seeing like
Tommy's perspective oh sorry cut that
we're not going to talk about that
actually
um but you know going back to what I was
just saying um just I thought you made a
really I mean the trailers they show you
it's credited in IMDb and they're
sharing the trailers of War
I imagine would see the day without
spoiling anything I'd imagine we'd and
they mentioned the character in the last
episode so I feel like we can slightly
say this Riley they mentioned the name
Riley in the last episode and I feel
like would probably get a flashback
where we get to see of course so we're
definitely getting that but I mean again
I just I like how they're really setting
it up with okay we're gonna focus at
least so far through two episodes we're
gonna focus on moments in the past a
little bit of non-linear storytelling
and then go back to the present I I
think it's a nice touch I like it
because it it sets the mood and the tone
for the rest of the episode well I also
love there's so much to love about this
show like there's nothing there's
nothing I don't like about it it's even
like I had a little bit of I I had it as
I really liked Bello Ramsay in the in
the first episode I imagine there's a
lot of people who loved her right away I
really liked her and this episode I was
like on board I love her yeah and um and
then when you go even the littlest
especially felt it with the clicker
scene and and it's Joel and Ellie and
they're duck down together I'm like oh
my God it's Ellie and Joe like that
moment right there was and then from
then on out
yeah I just had that moment with the
show of they did it they did the most
important thing to me and I think for
you too
it's like yeah with Beyond just bringing
the visuals there's so much you have to
nail yeah but one of the most important
things you gotta nail is Ellie and Joel
the most important thing you got to
bring them to life they got to make it
their own and they gotta have great
chemistry and and I had those aha
moments of yeah that's that's them
they've brought my favorite video game
characters to life and in a way that
does again that doesn't feel like you
know cosplay or some [__] like that yes
it feels like they've it's cool it's so
cool how they they made it their own yet
it feels like it's completely honoring
the source material that was one of the
things I loved about Gabriel Luna I hope
I said the name right this time yeah
that's one of the things I loved about
Gabriel Luna in the first episode like
is that Jeffrey Pierce talking or is
that Gabriel lunatucky it's just like
him but no I agree with you like I liked
uh Bella Ramsay in the first episode but
this episode just playing again the very
first scene she had yeah you're like oh
she's selling yeah yeah the the
character moments but not only that it's
just the way she's again the foul mouth
smart ass that she's being I'm like this
is just
Ellie Ellie Ellie it's like ah I love it
and again the reporter and Joel have
just that one little awkward
conversation that scene was so endearing
I really enjoyed that a lot I just where
Tess was uh trying to get the door open
and they were just having that
conversation came to know each other a
little like this is how it begins their
relationship oh I love that well that
scene I mean riffing off of that that's
kind of what I of why I was so invested
in Tess even more is because they're
letting you earn the relationships much
like they're spending so much more time
yeah like when you play the games the
first game is significantly shorter
compared to the second game
significantly the second game is like
Infinity it feels like it won't end and
I love it yes I agree whereas whereas
the first game you know uh you don't you
definitely don't spend this much time
with develop with allowing you to earn
the trust with Ellie like for our for
Tess and Joel they
I wouldn't say they speed through it
because they suddenly don't speed
through it but you get there quicker
correct and here they really take their
time like them having a standoff with
her when she wakes up oh that was
beautiful wonderful addition because
they're like we have no idea what you
are and and what's going on in your
child and even with Joel having to
really learn so the addition of her
getting bitten again
like in the game she just says like this
was three weeks ago right yeah but but
to have it be that much more of a
concrete proof for an instant yeah test
you're right she did just get she got
bit a while ago and uh she just got bit
like now and it was like an hour ago and
also Tess just had been bitten an hour
ago and you can tell the difference on
which one is periodically way worse yeah
yeah and so having that immediate
parallel between the two bites works
much stronger in this medium uh when
you're doing your adaptation so yeah
again I'd like another another great
addition to it yeah no I mean it's just
they're just making again through two
episodes such smart choices just things
they're adding on things they're subtly
changing I mean they're still being so
fate that what I love about this is
they're still being so faithful to the
game while adding and satisfactory and
really
smart and interesting things that move
the plot forward and give us Great
Character moments that's all I care
about while staying pretty faithful and
they're just achieving on all ends in
every Department in my opinion yeah now
they just gotta find dead bodies and
where everyone leaves letters behind yes
and safe and safe so we got to get those
combo locks open there's some good stuff
we got to get them searching around
looking for uh they gotta pick up rails
and supplies they're gonna get a whole
bunch of things gotta spend time with
the important stuff here
oh
they're gonna do a lot of unnecessary
it's like Joel why do you keep running
to every corner of the room you never
know there's every drawer and every
Locker be disappointed once in a while
when you spend time to open it it might
be ammo in there yeah
oh there's so much fun to be had yeah uh
but no I mean I feel like it's pretty
much everything with this episode right
because it was it was great they're I
think they're doing everything right
that clicker scene was a hard time nail
down I I was really impressed with that
clicker scene I'm really curious too if
they got the same people who did the
clicker motion body motion stuff for the
video games like because they do mocap
right with the game yeah and the games
of smoke caps I'm like let's just get
the same people back like that's what I
would have done but if they did not get
the same actors or actresses back like
whoever great job either way God I just
love that show whether they're looking
at the city and you have Ellie and Joe
dirty oh my God what a it is Ellie and
Joel oh hello so much and also too I
wanna I kind of mentioned a little bit
while we were reacting to it as well I
think Bella Ramsay just does a really
good job of also another thing she nails
of Ellie's that sense of awe and
Adventure that she that you can tell
also that sense of fear like when she
runs into clickers for the first time
like that's what I feel like she's got
wide range as an actress or she can do
all these different types of emoting and
and facial uh Expressions so I was
really impressed while also getting the
smart ass down and and just again her
chemistry with Pedro Pascal there it
really feels like Troll and Ellie I just
I I love it and again love how much of a
smart ashy was all episode just the the
Rapport those two have with each other
how they're just bouncing back and just
going at each other it's just it's pure
Joel and Elliott I love it yeah and you
can only feel it growing and also the
way Petra Pascal is doing the role I
love just how much more dejected he is
because I I sort of associated
um oh my God Troy Baker uh like Troy
Baker's uh it was a little bit more
aggressive I would say you know what I
mean yeah and
Churchill's violent and aggressive here
but he's a lot more
um like I said in the direction he's so
much more depressed and it works so well
for this too you know like he's got that
edge he's got that aggression and stuff
but you you could feel a lot more of
that sadness on display which is
something maybe you missed just with the
idea of like the the animation uh
Department of of a video game but now I
feel like they still get Detroit Baker
just plays a little more aggressive
whereas he's a little more soft-spoken
yeah I agree with you on one other cool
detail where I I kind of said I see
something but I didn't want to actually
spoil it I could see when when they were
running to the State Building I could
see a little bit of the bite mark from
Tess that's why when I said I see
something so I thought they suddenly
like were hiding it but can yeah I was
like maybe they're gonna see her for
episode three yeah yeah but obviously I
wasn't gonna spoil and say everyone just
got a bite marker on her neck but I like
how they subtly weren't kind of showing
but also people who are watching the
reaction I've already seen the episodes
but unless of course it's gonna happen a
later episode then we can't right right
of course but still um I thought that
was really well hidden detail that they
that again the attention to detail in
this episode and also too that actress
who plays Tess fantastic job incredible
incredible and also too the desperation
and the Hope again how she's able to
emote and give those facial reactions
and and have the wide range I mean these
the these actors and actresses in the
show they're through two episodes
fantastic job so far trying to find
something I don't like
it's hard I'm really trying to be like
what what don't I'd like damn you Neil
druck because this is so far very
compelling and and it doesn't it's for
this thing from disappointing and again
my biggest fear again through two
episodes they've gone past my fears my
biggest fears were are they gonna nail
the Joel and Ellie episode so far
through two episodes check and my other
biggest fear is this gonna be a carbon
copied just like the video game and so
far check it's mainly character based
which is the game in a lot of ways but a
lot of times with video game adaptations
you're left with the even for games I
haven't played but I watched the movies
yeah I go I'm I feel like I might as
well just play the video
like that's how it ends at me because
they focus so much on the the action
scenes or some [__] like that and the
story sucks so much whereas here's the
exact opposite it's like even the way
they do the action scenes it's not
making me think oh I'd rather be playing
the game instead like I'm so pulled into
the action of how it's going down that
not once am I going I wish I just had a
controller so I was doing this myself
which is a lot of the times video game
adaptations can make me feel so yeah I
thought this was uh
this is pretty great so far I hope they
keep it up yeah sure and it's uh I mean
yeah the level of quality of this TV
show it's it's fantastic through two
episodes I am so locked into this I'm
loving it all right guys well what did
you think of the second episode leave
your thoughts down below be sure to
subscribe leave a like and um check us
on patreon we'll catch it all soon
foreign